Oh going there my name River welcome
back to spinning the win I'm spinning it
as been in a gift someone out no no yeah
he's high you [ __ ] what is your idea
does let down [ __ ] like it guys so
[ __ ] pimp you doesn't even care
[ __ ] you're driving my intro and [ __ ]
well we're in the morgue which is bad
I'm told that this mod just gets scarier
and scarier
I guess we're at the scarier scarier
part cuz it's already been pretty
[ __ ] scary if you had me scary Gary
alright I'm sure nothing bad will happen
in it ah all these young leaders doing
here ah nah we take the dead bodies and
put them in a ball back
uh-huh then we put them in the IRA fight
drain their blood so we see here to
examine yeah yeah that's a nice huh no
IRA made him
no no no no no no no someone here how
whoa whoa wasn't you're the guy who
killed me oh this is problem man I don't
know it was so much blood
second endless blood blood they didn't
drain the blood very well what is that
my go ahead die do I let you fret as all
I hate them where's the Easter egg key I
gotta find that [ __ ] uh
I guess we got to go down here unless we
go down here yeah we go down here I
don't want to go to the ball
I don't like balls uh okay I like balls
why I'm sorry I'm sorry I can't think
when I'm in situating right now it's not
that easy all right let's go here say
hello to the ball I'm sorry I rejected
you ball please ah no there's iron man
yeah I [ __ ]
this is gonna be bad all right don't
kill me ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba
Oh
oh great oh that's fun no no no no no no
what is this [ __ ] spider
get out of here spider what is wrong
what the hell are you doing giving oral
in front of people man
it's not cold bully well I didn't do
anything that's what I got in it what
get down to my face ah stop stop
I hate those [ __ ] all right
that's fine that's fine
open hush do-do-do-do-do that's good
hey Sam stop stop stop it not funny
anymore
you [ __ ] fat burrs spiders don't
fight all right I didn't even know I was
spidered I don't even want to know what
a spider day look like mine Saturday so
[ __ ] low right now
I was fine wait fine what I need to talk
to ya I want to talk your head of the
combination to the log to the coast ah
yeah go through the gates or head ah
okay down here yeah why not why not ah
oh come our blood I love that attic
oh the [ __ ] am i doing I'm all iron
maiden I can get in there anyway go so
sorry about this
what the fact that a goat what the
father that what manage that [ __ ]
instead of running and running and
running it no no I don't know what the
[ __ ] you're getting Giggy we're good
we're good we're good we'll get we'll
get we're good we're good we're good
pivot row they tells me baby
the God the God bro tell me what go it
out you must go over here bad all right
I'm good what ha ha you tried to kill me
headache what the hell is that what is
that leave me here on this island
thing there you go bro that's nice it
looks good on you it looks like you're
wearing a dress it's nice thanks Bailey
ah [ __ ] but it's got what is this I
don't want to go here hey Shh don't
distract me right now don't distract
pity right now barely thinking can do
two things at once
HHH
all right let's not go there right now
you know Wow
well I don't [ __ ] know I really don't
know but I do know how that was I don't
know what the [ __ ] that would have said
your daughter or something cow Matt
gotten a job cry focusing on this oh why
didn't I just go in here this is a
puzzle I need fuel
so I pee in here is that it you want my
urine machine I don't think she'll add
things up for one second
he'll what's that [ __ ] thing I don't
get it I don't get anything where did he
go I don't know if I want to know okay
so I guess we got to lift this gate and
by doing so sorry about that mister
all right keep going ah ah get out of my
face you slimy piece of [ __ ] all right
all right way ahh it's only one way you
got a signature aha
she's got a girder ahahaha
this way bad I told you a million hands
man you have to look at spelling okay
fine it's great happy for you alright
you will go fart no don't let me go
why not bro [ __ ] don't fall on bruh to
hell man
so can we welcome this or what don't do
it better don't
ah whoa bro I didn't mean to do that
well alright I guess we can oh okay you
just go here it's fine
good thing I'm such an acrobatic person
in general so I don't know I get the
feeling they want us to go there
oh that sons a [ __ ] tricked me didn't
they
oh there's a lighter there I see you
later I see I acknowledge your ex I got
down we're going down aren't red oh
sorry [ __ ] the son of a [ __ ] it's not
good is it if I go down here there's no
way out oh the goat cannot possibly go
down here I mean it's ridiculous it's no
way that waiting huh No
it's cool like they use new monsters and
[ __ ] but I don't know what I feel about
it kind of be honest let's go up that's
nice
I'm going up glowing spider way cool
okay more glaring spotlight ah every
[ __ ] thing is blocked there isn't it
well it is up anyway pattern yeah what a
hell is your problem I thought I to stay
there
alright stay that don't go anywhere
we're good alright let's go in here ah a
pot oh cool we need just one more then
got the old best alright
can't stop saying it it's a jack pens
reference here we go Matt they're closed
some kind of phew
no no what a lien on ma no yes okay uh
Papa mama no bad bad seal what the hell
it to Narnia ah I'm getting right up we
can't write him can't write him I know
you love me I know you care for a dududu
son of a [ __ ]
I'm so [ __ ] out of here so I'm so
[ __ ] POG
oh no no no no
why the [ __ ] am i singing hi slow as
[ __ ] at least that's good ah son of a
[ __ ]
oh no no no why that sound I hate that
son okay with Jason fidgety yeah ah
don't go down too funky down now again
then go down to foger down question is
if we need one more fuel ah no no save
yes
ah what is your problem
ah yeah I'm poor I'm home - yeah
you're a pump that's cold so there
should be fuel in here I mean they got a
safe station here it's got to be some
reason for this room to happen
wait kind of stuff recording for a
second Suzanne hate you whoa that's good
that's progress
finally maybe we can find some oil in
here or fuel whatever is we need I
wouldn't probably go in here especially
without Oh No oh I think all right let's
see what we can find it is Oh letter I
love me some ladders that's good all
right
man what's up here this can't be good no
I can't begin this is bad news
what the hell are you know right here
twist my nipples better twist up ah I
don't want to twist your nipples
push down better do it quick but what
will happen if I don't don't worry about
it you're good
I don't want to twist anything [ __ ] yeah
what the hell okay I'm twisting I'm
flash tag but hmm
shut up a little bit okay okay I can
move it a son of a [ __ ] why did I jump
it I know it I know it all what pathetic
how do you pitch not now Jennifer not
now all right give it you'll never get
your nipples bless
what is Go Go ha
that's how I roll that's how I get on
the ladies this room was pointless
wasn't it I didn't get [ __ ] from it
didn't I
ah no it was pointless I know it's gotta
be as fuel but instead it to scare me
didn't eh ah come on those bastards
I'm so sad right now why do they make me
do that
Susanne shut up in there like go in
there again
what about ya know I likes ya alright
looks like we'll have to end this
episode here I'm glad but anyway like
various you enjoyed subscribe comment
today and I'll see you next episode of
whatever I may stay awesome bros i know
you're well no no no no no no no no no
no
Oh